hi I'm Nick Gillespie from reason TV we
are in Las Vegas at Freedom Fest that we
are talking to the author George Gilder
is certainly one of the more
controversial and influential authors of
the past 40 years really George thanks
for talking with great to be here your
latest book is the Israel test what is
the Israel test the Israel test is one
to response to people who excel you and
some feel during most of the 20th
century the Israel test has been the
Jewish test because Jews created much of
of World Science and Technology won the
Second World War through the Manhattan
Project that Jews have always punched
above their weight but you're not this
isn't the Jewish test to see is this the
Israel test today Israel distills the
genius of the Jews and and is a vital
asset for the United States because it
can't afford all indulgences and and
debt and crazy green policy and well and
this is camera phobia it's born out of
the necessity that Israel is everywhere
surrounded by enemies most of whom won't
even acknowledge its right to exist by
the same token you're a huge free market
advocate Israel is also a very socialist
country reasonably but it's it's moved
more radically toward the right than
virtually any other country in the world
that's current government as a
supply-side free-market operation that
operates under the gun so it has a big
defense efforts but it's essentially
drastically reus
taxes tax rates its deregulated most of
its economy it's deregulated its entire
financial sector its deregulated its
pension system previously was totally
run by the history drew the big public
labor union now it's yielding four
hundred million dollars a month
into the private sector finance what
what explains Jewish achievement and in
Israel Israeli achievement well Jews for
centuries have been banished from owning
land or or even many forms of property
I've been driven into intellectual
pursuits from and they have refined
those intellectual pursuits and now
we're in an economy of mind and the
Israelis have adapted to the global
economy of mind better than any other
ethnic group so it's really a kind of
cultural evolution I mean we're not of
not necessarily of Jews choosing but
they were forced to you know they were
kicked out of England they were kicked
out of Spain they were kicked out of
anywhere and they developed a culture
that really privileged education and
entrepreneurial spirit and all and in
Israel of course they million Russians
who had worked under a communist regime
and were virtually prohibited from doing
anything material or in manufacturing
because that was totally socialized so
those guys those guys were forced into
software algorithms and mathematics and
a million of them came to Israel and
just burned all the socialist
indulgences and fantasies that
previously governed Israeli society so
what's the I mean if that's why they're
doing well how do we adapt that say to
the United States or to Western Europe
or to South America or to China well
elect a supply-side regime
I mean Bibi Netanyahu of went MIT and
then went and worked for the Boston
Consulting Group at the very time it was
providing the foundations of supply-side
economics economics is going to make us
all a little bit Jewish but what does
that mean in terms of you know if we if
we've got to get sharper with our minds
how is supply-side economics going to
how was I've been for thousands of years
of cultural level because it focuses on
the mind
capitalism is based on kaput I had it's
the creative form of economics that it
focuses on what makes human beings
unique rather than our common prairie
and interests and morbid fears and
anxieties it focuses on our curiosities
and aspirations and creativity and re
activity always comes as a supply as a
surprise to us so it can't be planned
well one of the things you know speaking
about supply-side economics you wrote
wealth and poverty which is generally
considered the Bible of the supply-side
economics that emerged in the late 70s
as a major bestseller major influence on
Ronald Reagan's economic policies part
of what you talked about in that book is
how entrepreneurs are a part of a gift
economy I mean you helped revive the
Marcel Mauss idea of the gift economy
talk a little bit about that and do you
still believe that yeah sure
entrepreneurs have to invest they have
to give they have to create before
there's any assured response to their
creations there's no demand for new
innovations they you could demand
innovation
you wouldn't socialism would work so
it's I mean it's it's a fallacy and we
saw this with the iPad and the iPod and
the iPhone before that people saying
like oh of course everybody wants the
iPad we've always wanted it but in fact
there was no demand for the iPad right
and and and that's true about all
innovations that's why as a supply-side
by unleashing individual creativity
creates wealth and progress and all
other systems suppress wealth and so but
now let's talk about supply-side
economics because that's that since you
know the supply-side economics and
starve the beast kind of got commingled
in a way that I think has tarnished
supply-side economics at
I had nothing to do with stars right but
let's explain what you're saying I think
it is a beast yet I and it should be
starved
but I've one of my insights that I saw
was the best way to measure the success
of tax policy is how much government
spending Rises and countries with lower
declining tax rates increase their
government spending three times as fast
as governments with high or rising tax
rates and that's because they grow six
times faster that means government is
growing smaller as a part of a bigger
economy but and government has more
money to spend though in absolute terms
yes yeah let's talk about some of your
other books because I for me as a
longtime reader of your work you know it
seems that your books get split into a
kind of dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde approach
where there are books that are about
social issues where you're a pretty
Rockridge social conservative looks like
sexual suicide or Invisible Man
the residual man excuse me yeah and the
the revision of sexual suicide as of men
and marriage and then there are the
books that are a pretty utopian and we
can argue whether or not they're utopian
or they're descriptive but things like
life after television telecom and
whatnot and you were one of Wired's
great original poster boys cover boys
how do you square sexual suicide for
instance argued in the early seventies
in response to kind of breaking down of
traditional gender roles that we were we
were going to destroy our society and
yet then you were also later
promulgating a kind of series of
technologies that would allow us but to
indulge our wildest fantasies but
reconfigure ourselves almost independent
of bodies does do you see a conflict or
attention in your so how do you square
those circles it's just the family is
critical to raising civilized creative
responsible people who can exploit
freedom and enjoy freedom themselves and
freedom how are you
finding the family and that the nuclear
family and the man and woman and
children is a where how do you feel
about New York legalizing gay marriage
it's a good thing I think it's a bad
thing I don't why is it bad I mean gays
can do what they want to do but I don't
believe that it you know now bisexuality
is supposedly factored duh I mean if the
fact is all of us are bisexual in
various ways that this whole idea that
that homosexuality resembles race in any
respect is nonsense the whole idea that
male homosexuality resembles lesbianism
in any respect is nonsense and so this
whole idea a good way marriage is just a
parody it's it's a it's an absurd well
do you think that you know a say two gay
men who are married would they be able
to create a stable family situation that
would raise children who would be Fleur
who would flourish on the Internet sure
individuals can do all kinds of things
it's it's different when you're
establishing principles that are going
to govern this society and that the
chief problem with gay marriage to me I
don't particularly care what they choose
to do but the result will be teaching
young kids that gay sex is just as good
as any other sex which is have you ever
had gay sex do you know is it as good I
know enough I've spent a long time
studying this subject and and I know
about gay sex more than most of the
people who talk about it it was such
Authority and it's it's not it is not
procreative it cannot sustain the race
and young boys are quite responsive to
it and so it's a mistake
to open this door for confused boys who
have yet crystallized their sexual
orientation and and it's a it's an
addictive form of behavior and recent
studies showed that during the until
about 21 our brains are very responsive
to various forms of addiction and the
earlier they're inculcated the more so
gay gay predisposition or is is really a
learned behavior yeah it's it's it's a
gayness is about 50 percent genetic like
everything else like alcoholism any kind
of behavior this sort is as shown by
twin studies about 50% genetic and the
other 50% is is environment and choice
and I don't think that 50% of twin
studies are just completely esta their
twin studies are about the best week
breath access we can get to these forms
of causation
to to shift to the other emphasis in
your work about the kind of ways in
which technology you know are
transformative life after television you
essentially force saw that not not the
internet per se it existed but the
flourishing of the World Wide Web
lassen life yeah as well and the if when
you were in dispensing we're away well
yeah yeah
has it paid off on your vision of that
it was going to reinvigorate I mean I
remember reading that book and one of
the things that was fascinating is that
you you anticipated the arguments that
this was going to atomize people or push
people apart and in fact you you were
saying that it would help to create new
forms of community but also invigorate
traditional forums do you feel that that
is been borne out yeah absolutely you
know it it creates a huge new avenue for
all forms of human expression and that's
a good thing and that's a good thing
yeah I mean and and the medium
libertarian yeah I don't if the
is is inherently libertarian or it's a
decentralized mechanism or framework or
grammar that allows us to speak a
different language I mean are we already
in a libertarian world oh we are yeah
but that's that that is true that that
is the impact that overcomes the tyranny
of Broadcast top-down hierarchical
cultural system do you miss the days
when you you could feel secure that not
only you but everybody else had seen
Walter Cronkite speaking I've never had
a TV in my home I love my life so I have
no idea what would about Walter cracken
what do you think we know what he looks
like what do you think explains the
nostalgia that you find among many
conservatives but perhaps more
surprisingly among many liberals are
leftist for that day when people were
not as free to express themselves they
want the comforts of bland and creative
society what do you think is I mean you
you anticipated the you know the impact
of the World Wide Web you talked about
it would lead to a golden age of text
yeah and it is certainly true you know
forget the Gutenberg galaxy and we're
living it I think yeah so what do what
do you anticipate or what do you see as
the next huge transformative kind of
technological development I I think that
every Moore's law means that every 10
years there's a complete transformation
of computer architecture and the change
that's emerging is cloud computing and
which means that anybody anywhere can
have access to total supercomputer
capabilities or even transou per
computer over computer capabilities and
I've got a company in Los Angeles called
Oh toy that is when several Academy
Awards for its light stage technology
but also is building the world's fastest
computer out of clusters of Grass
fix processors and that can be a
petaflop machine anywhere around the
world
Murdo which can mean that your
teleporter can or your which is your
smartphone is they call it it can do
anything that a supercomputer can do are
you you're optimistic about the future
yes yeah so what are what are the things
that can that can ruin the future for us
well we got a absolutely stupid third
worldly president at the moment who
wants to reduce the United States to
some third-world backwater and that way
I mean responds to the upper class
intellectuals of who you know bailed
over with a cast of green goop and I
think it's I think the environmental
movement and the effort to suppress all
energy production is virtually vandala
sztyc and so I think this is the worst
president I've ever seen a little earth
worldly though I mean it because he he
wants to bring us down to the level does
he does he want to or is it that will be
the effect you're saying I think I mean
does he hate America or is he just he
resents capitalism he resents the wealth
that capitalism generates he resents the
inequalities that are indispensable to
any creative and free society winner
manifested what do you face that on
other than the way that you see his
policies working what is that a psycho
history or psycho biography well it's
just evident to me I mean he he studied
with Edward Sayid and Rashid Khalidi was
his press secretary Reverend Wright was
his preacher Bill Ayers and Bernardine
Dohrn we're his pals and intellectual
will that win are you just it just is a
hardcore leftist that's what he is and
he may escape it he may transcend it as
he proceeds but so far he's totally
failed by me
I mean what he's doing to the US energy
economy today is you know couldn't be
done by a nuclear attack I mean it's
it's devastating and destructive and
it's and it and he's got to be thrown
out as a result of this do you see
anybody you know within the Republican
Party or you know not even that I mean
even in the Democratic Party or who are
the people who are making the right
counter arguments to this because it's
not like you know I can't imagine that
anybody on the Republican side of the
aisle is inspiring you to say yeah
they're really getting the next
generation of technology or the next I
think I think any of the Republicans are
a lot better
I mean if Newt wasn't such a jerk
I would he's the smartest and as what
that's what I do because he was
obviously suddenly all these polls is
the is demand-side transcribed into
politics you're constantly looking at a
rearview mirror so there are two really
destructive forces and our politics and
one is polls which is reduces everybody
to a blithering idiot
and following polls and the other is our
campaign finance laws that currently
allow special interest groups to spend
any amount they want but reduce
individuals who actually are arild
entities in politics to two thousand
bucks a campaign and and this is a major
factor in our politics and the
combination of polls and special
interests has what has really brought
our current system to its current of
light the final question you would
describe yourself as a libertarian what
what what are the what's the basic right
fit for government what should it be
wanted they got a defense and
you know law upholding the law
you do need a structure of law in order
to have free economy but the information
theory is what I'm really working on
more than anything else these days and
it shows that you need a low entropy
carrier that is with no surprises to
bear high entropy creations and this
comes from telecommunications analysis
Claude Shannon's vision of
telecommunications but it applies across
the board so you need regularities in
the law in order to unleash creativity
and enterprise so should the government
be engaging social issues the way that
it does or should that be something that
is hashed out in the marketplace of
ideas and I'd love to get I mean yes it
should be hashed out in the marketplace
of ideas rather than having government I
think that laws about marriage make
sense I don't and but limited set of
laws are desirable and the real cancer
of capitalism is when lawyers start
manipulating the law in order to favor
litigation and conflict and and enriched
lawyers
well George Gilder I want to thank you
very much for talking to Reason TV your
latest book his latest book is the
Israel test and hopefully will all pass
that with flying colors I hope so
they're written for it's important for
reason TV I'm Nicola
you